[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الظروف الجويه لمده طويله تسمى بالمناخ
والمده القصيره تسمى بالطقس والطقس تاثيره
على الحاله النفسيه والمناخ تاثيره على
الحاله الشكليه فسكنات وحركات الخليقه
برمتها متوقف على الطقس فالق الاصباح وجعل
الليل سكنا والشمس والقمر حسبانا ذلك
تقدير العزيز العليم وجعلنا الليل لباسا
وجعلنا النهارة معاشا واشكال الخليقه
متوقف على المناخ فسكان شرق الكره الارضيه
يختلفون عن غربها وشمالها يختلفون عن
جنوبها وشعاع الشمس له تاثير على السواد
فكلما زاد التعامد زاد سواد وكل من كسرت
شعاع الشمس زاد البياض فالافارقه شكلهم
لون البشره ولون الشعر مجعد واسود وكذلك
العيون لان الشمس متعامده عليهم
والاوروبيين لونهم ابيض وشعرهم ذهب
وعيونهم ايضا مذهبه والعرب بين هذا وذاك
لا تقل اصلي وفصلي ابدا انما اصل الفتى ما
قد حصل قد يسود المرء من دون اب وبحسن
السبك قد تبقى الدول انما الورد من الشوك
وما ينبت النرجس الا من بصل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]